mit refugee action hub react is an
education pathway for displaced
communities globally
we really believe in investing in
emerging talent helping them become
creative change agents for not only
their careers but their communities
it was challenging for me because i
didn't have any documents
i fled my account to come here to look
for peace but did not have any document
that i can show
[Music]
as people migrate to new communities
they might need to not only start over
their education but their career and
that
ability to pivot really depends on how
are they going to be recognized within
their new community and so this is where
how important
digital credentials certificates degrees
are in somebody's ability to navigate a
new employment ecosystem and so
react is really around providing that
recognition for talented youth who are
motivated to advance their education and
career but due to circumstances might
have been locked out of those
opportunities
the program was amazing to be honest i
can't describe the way it has changed my
life even the way of thinking in terms
of being an entrepreneur yeah
what we basically do with react we
we bring the opportunity for students to
prove themselves
through
education and education
becomes the catalyst of
change
in the community where they live
react is building a community of global
hubs so we partner with universities
companies and ngos on the ground that
help provide access for our students to
laptops to community spaces to
additional mentorship and internships
i ended up as a refugee in croatia and
italian volunteers would come
come into our camp and and basically
bring a lot of
joy to a kid
like myself
i learned from them that we really need
to
activate ourselves and do things be
doers
the growing refugee crisis in ukraine is
just the latest powerful example of this
is really waking people up to what
displacement means
and how it can impact a life and how do
we create these kinds of pathways for
people to not only move but to restart
you